et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
rafik chez quatre avocats cofondateur de
l'association action contre
l'islamophobie bonsoir à rafik chez 4
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés pour
débattre julien aux 12 membres du bureau
national du rn conseiller municipal de
sens bon soir julien on dit merci
également à vous d'être là c'est donc
une affaire qui a fait bondir un haut
niveau des politiques de droit à temps
et d'extrême droite ou le week-end
regardez par exemple le tweet de la
présidence du rassemblement national
marine le pen ferment le conte d'une
jeune femme harcelée et menacée par les
islamistes twitter a choisi le camp des
ennemis de la démocratie
il est temps de protéger la liberté
d'expression face aux pouvoirs
exorbitants de ses plateformes privées
et leurs abus répétés briller twitter
qui a donc choisi le camp des ennemis de
la démocratie pour marine le pen est ce
que vous partagez cet avis rafik chez
cat
alors avant toute chose j'aimerais
relever l'ironie qu'il ya discuté de la
question de la liberté d'expression avec
un homme donc avec monsieur julien odoul
qui s'est fait connaître du grand public
justement parce qu'il s'est opposé à la
liberté d'expression d'une femme d'une
femme musulmane
c'est à dire qu'il s'est opposé à la
liberté religieuse d'une femme élancée
que cette liberté religieuse est
constitutive de la liberté d'expression
dont je voulais juste relever cette
ironie qui consiste à discuter de cette
question là avec ce monsieur
ensuite j'ai une impression que avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet que la
liberté d'expression en france n'est
invoquée que pour revendiquer le droit
d'insulter les musulmanes et les
musulmans c'est à dire que quand des
lanceurs d'alert sont menacés sont
traînés en justice durant des années
sans condamner à payer des amendes
records pour avoir révélé des
malversations financières ou économiques
politiques des scandales politiques ou
bien même des catastrophes écologiques
environnementales
personne ne s'inquiète la d atteinte
manifeste est flagrante à la liberté
d'expression de la même manière toutes
les personnes qui aujourd'hui comme
monsieur oudoul et comme le
rassemblement national monte au créneau
pour défendre milla on aimerait beaucoup
les entendre aussi quand la liberté de
manifester qui est une autre
liberté d'expression est battu en brèche
systématiquement est quasiment chaque
week end à la majorité actuelle
c'est-à-dire que quand le fait de
manifester quand le fait de manifester
ses opinions politiques à l'occasion
d'un mouvement social vous expose
aujourd'hui très concrètement en france
à être menacée à être gazés à être
mutilés où sont les curés ou sont tous
les défenseurs de la liberté
d'expression à ce moment là de la même
manière et je terminerai là dessus oui
quand la liberté d'exprimer ses opinions
politiques des militants de la campagne
bds est battu en brèche également quand
on empêche les militants de la campagne
bds d'exprimer des opinions politiques
c'est à dire le boycott des produits
israéliens en soutien aux populations
palestiniennes personnes là aussi ne
s'enquiert de la liberté d'expression
donc j'ai vraiment l'impression que la
liberté d'expression en france n'étant
invoquées que l'on va on va laisser le
droit de réponse à julien odoul oui ne
me parlez pas de liberté expression
monsieur chez 4 ne me parlez pas de
liberté d'expression
vous qui être l'avocat du cause qui est
la cause de l'islamisme
il n'ya pas d'islamophobie en france ce
système aux phobiques est un concept
inventé de toutes pièces par les ennemis
notre démocratie par les ennemis de nos
valeurs par les ennemis de nos libertés
justement pour interdire toute critique
de cette idéologie nauséabonde mortifère
qu'est l'islamisme
voilà alors vous voyez excusez moi moi
la liberté d'expression oui je la veux
total total c'est à dire que milla cette
jeune lycéenne qui est persécuté depuis
un an
persécuté menacé de mort qui a été
déscolarisés parce qu'elle a donné son
opinion a donné son opinion sur une
autre opinion parce que la religion
musulmane comme toutes les religions en
droit français n'est qu'une opinion une
opinion qui peut être critiqué avec
outrance
voilà c'est notre mode de vie c'est le
droit on peut critiquer une religion le
coup de france n'a pas le droit de
s'attaquer aux croyants on n'a pas le
droit de s'attaquer à des personnes pour
leurs convictions religieuses mais on a
droit
évidemment de critiques et de s'attaquer
à une religion et même on a le droit
d'en avoir peur voyez on a le droit en
france d'être cathophobes être
judéophobe être islamophobe donc ne me
parlez pas de liberté d'expression parce
que le
baky le vôtre l'entreprise qui est la
vôtre elle cherche justement à museler
la société française et à faire en sorte
que l'idéologie qui est derrière est
encore une fois qui est extrêmement
dangereuse pour la préservation de nos
libertés cette idéologie s'installe donc
moi je trouve ça scandaleux
en tout cas que des encore une fois que
des françaises et des français comme
milla mais comme d'autres soient
censurées à la fois sur les réseaux
sociaux mais soit surtout menacée
aujourd'hui de mort pour leurs opinions
effectivement il avait été menacé de
mort cette adolescente 1 en janvier 2020
après avoir publié une vidéo qui
critiquaient durement les slama autres
réactions politiques
aujourd'hui celle du député européen
socialiste dans cette fois raphaël
enthoven
rendez-nous 1000 à quand une femme est
menacée de mort c'est elle qu'on protège
pas les assassins putatif
attention les cons ceci n'est pas une
insulte et leurs graphiques chez 4 c'est
vrai que sur le message quand on a
enlevé le comte 2001 il y avait indiqué
un tweeter suspend les comptes qui
enfreignent les règles de twitter c'est
vrai que cette confusion entre celui
qu'on doit protéger celui qu'on attaque
c'est un petit peu compliqué vous
comprenez que ça ait pu choquer à droite
comme à gauche on viens de l'entendre je
vais pas redire ce que j'ai dit sur le
double standard est la manière dont on
est choqué pour certaines atteintes et
non pour d'autres moins très honnêtement
sur l'inter milan ils sont sept jeunes
filles
j'ai pas vraiment je les mêmes aucune
opinion sur cette personne d'ailleurs
que je vais pas me mettre à commenter
les tweets que tout jeune personne fait
sur twitter
c'est absolument pas de mon ressort par
contre j'aimerais dire une chose qui
peut paraître surprenante c'est que j'en
veux à toutes les personnes qui ont
servi de caisse de résonance à cette
jeune femme à cette jeune personne qui
tweets sur twitter
moi je suis pour que les personnes
puissent écrire à peu près ce qu'elles
veulent sur les réseaux sociaux et
notamment sur twitter velléités mais
c'est pour ça qu'elle a été médiatisée
elle a été vraiment menacé lors
d'escales est déscolarisé s'est tassée
et moi j'en vois exactement à toutes les
personnes qui ont servi et je le redis
de caisse de résonance à cette personne
parce que c'est huit sont insignifiants
sa pensée politique et ces opinions sont
parfaitement insignifiante et je ne
comprends même pas qu'on puisse monter
on n'est pas qu'une affaire comme ça
donc je vous le dis j'en veux aux toutes
les personnes qui relaie cette personne
lilas qui devrait rester dans l'anonymat
tekki temps dans l'anonymat pardon qui
devrait être le sien qui aurait dû être
le sien aujourd'hui
jelly roll oui mais malheureusement
aujourd'hui milla ne peut pas être
anonyme
milla ne peut pas avoir la vie d'une
jeune fille française normal aujourd'hui
la vie de millas est un enfer et c'est
un enfer parce qu'elle est persécuté en
raison de ses opinions
elle est persécutée par des gens qui
peuvent se donner peuvent donner libre
cours à des discours de haine à la fois
sur les réseaux sociaux mais aussi dans
la société parce que ce que l'on peut
voir sur les réseaux sociaux
on le retrouve dans les entreprises on
le retrouve dans les clubs de sport on
le retrouve sur évidemment dans les
services publics on le retrouve à
l'école on le retrouve dans la vie
réelle et moi ce que je dénonce c'est le
deux poids deux mesures aussi parce que
milla le le k 2000 à vous en avez
d'autres évidemment vous avez les
professeurs de lieux paix à grenoble
vous avez tous ceux aujourd'hui qui
osent critiquer l'islam qui osent
critiquer le voile islamique qui ont se
défendre la laïcité tout simplement
qu'ils se retrouvent persécutés qui
subissent des fatwas et qui peuvent
quelquefois comme ça mais elle pâtit
comme le regretté sam elle pâtit peuvent
y laisser la vie
et moi ce que je regrette c'est que la
prétendue islamophobie qui est ce
concept voit la nébuleuse islamiste
la prétendue islamophobie elle n'existe
pas dans les faits et je prends juste un
exemple la jeune qui a menti sur samuel
pâti cette jeune élève du collège de
samuel pâtit donc qui a proféré ce
mensonge qui a conduit à la décapitation
de sa belle pâti cette jeune fille n'est
pas déscolarisés cette jeune fille n'est
pas persécutés et tant mieux pour elle
parce qu'évidemment je ne pense
qu'aujourd'hui elle subit les
conséquences de son acte mais cette
jeune fille a pu réintégrer son
établissement scolaire ce qui n'est pas
le cas de milles 1 mille a été
déscolarisés
aujourd'hui milla est tous sous
protection policière voilà la différence
entre des prétendues victimes d'
islamophobie est celle qui est ce qu'ils
sont taxés d'islamophobe qui pour le
coup vivent un enfer et sont menacés de
mort avant de vous faire réagir et rafik
chekade je voulais vous faire entendre
cette dernière réaction celle d'un
professeur d'histoire géo en
seine-saint-denis qui vient souvent
d'ailleurs débattre dans cette émission
voici ce qu'il en pense la ferme il a
restauré dans notre histoire récente
comme le symbole du renoncement de la
république à imposer ses valeurs à ce
qu'il a conclu c'est le communautarisme
qui l'emportent sur le vivre ensemble
c'est la loi coranique qui l'emportent
sur celles de la république
rafika chekade votre réaction c'est le
communautarisme qui l'emportent sur le
sur le vivre ensemble vous comprenez que
certains aujourd'hui puisse le penser
ou ça vous alors je lui demandai à ce
professeur d'histoire géographie de
définir tous les termes tu viens
d'employés après en premier lieu le
communautarisme le vivre ensemble etc
il serait bien en peine de donner une
définition précise de ces mots là donc
on agite sont ce qu'on appelle des
mots-valises le communautarisme c'est à
dire qu'il ya autant de définitions de
comme les jumeaux communautarise qu'il
ya personne qu'il utilise donc parler
aujourd'hui comme vient de le faire
monsieur odoul de cette personne qui ose
critiquer l'islam alors qu'il suffit
aujourd'hui d'allumer n'importe quelle
radio d'ouvrir n'importe quel journal
d'allumer n'importe quel poste de
télévision sur n'importe quelle chaîne
d'information continue pour voir que les
débats sur l'islam sont incessants la
semaine dernière c'étaient les ep de
grenoble après on discute de la question
de la pertinence du terme d'islamophobie
ou non et j'aimerais dire une chose
c'est que l'islamophobie est présente
dans tous les pays d'europe
évidemment toutes les sociétés
occidentales mayhem spécificité
française c'est que la france est à mon
sens le seul pays d'europe et de seul
coup la seule démocratie occidentale où
l'on discute à ce point de la pertinence
ou non de ce terme
et c'est révélateur du climat qu'il ya
dans ce pays donc vraiment moi tous les
propos qui consiste à dire que
d'islamophobie est un racisme qui
n'existe pas et c'est alors qu'on vient
de voter une loi la loi sais pas
attise qui vient entraver les personnes
musulmanes dans tous les aspects de leur
vie sociale que ce soit le travail
l'éducation
il vous est pas couper la parole
monsieur des c'est moi qui viens je ne
vous ai pas couper la parole et c'est
moi juste filière et c'est moi qui me
remet cieux je vous ai pas couper la
parole n'est pas content et là je me
suis dit non mais laissez moi finir
monsieur où tout le monde est finie
c'est plus on donnera 2 901 julien au
delà les et la contraction monsieur vos
12 c'est ma toute première télévision je
vous ai pas couper la parole et s'est
terminée si le secret parce qu'on arrive
au bout du débat je termine je termine
par dire que toutes les
il ya ne en france le terme islamophobie
est lié par les plus grands propagateurs
de l'islamophobie même et c'est ce qui
est intéressant et vous en êtes à la
manifestation ce soir monsieur au dos
j'ai les aubinois rapidement s'il vous
plaît le mot de la fin rapidement merci
la même monsieur je vous apprendre
quelque chose mais en france il n'y a
aucune loi qui entravent les nos
compatriotes de confession musulmane
pour la simple et bonne raison que la
religion passe après la noce nos
nationalités la citoyenneté
ils sont français avant tout il n'y a
pas d'exception n'a pas d'exception pour
les musulmans pour les catholiques
ils ont français avant tout voilà et
toutes les lois s'appliquent à tout le
monde
merci merci à tous les deux on sent
qu'un d'avoir accepté le jeu du face à
face et oui c'est le principe nous ne
sommes pas d'accord rafik chez ktm
julien odoul évidemment rafales entre
ben et bien philosophe et non pas député
européen socialiste veuillez nous
excuser pour cette erreur
merci à vous d'en